(light music)
- [Narrator] In the
waters around Sri Lanka,
you'll find the world's
only stilt fishermen.
Perched atop a handmade
stilt driven into the sand,
these fishermen are some
of the last of their kind.
But for those who still fish,
it is about carrying on a tradition
only found in this part of the world.
(light music)
(acoustic guitar music)
- [Narrator] The history of stilt fishing
is said to go back to World War II,
when food shortages and
a lack of proper boats
caused fishermen to get
creative for their catch.
Fishing from a stick offshore
helped them catch more fish.
(soft music)
- [Narrator] Fishing isn't
as lucrative as it once was,
so most stilt fishermen have
other jobs to pay the bills
but continue to stilt fish
to keep the tradition alive.
(soft music)
(high-pitched tone resounds)